foreign
students know who Witherspoon is that's
a shame they should but they probably
don't uh and the ones who want to get
rid of it are just motivated by chaos
motivated by this subjective left-wing
diversity Equity inclusion woke view of
the world that everything of the past
must be torn down unless they were
perfect based on the Judgment of today
John Witherspoon is an American hero who
is the only clergy to sign the
Declaration of Independence he was
recruited uh from Europe from Ireland to
be the president of Princeton he was a
contemporary of James Madison he was
considered a brilliant mind a lover of
Liberty uh and and a one of the early
ministers to run Prince and that's what
Prince used to do is train ministers uh
and so he's been revered there are Halls
named after him at Princeton he's
recognized as a hero When I Was An
undergraduate I believe it was in 2001
they put up a statue in fact we put up a
statue and a town in Ireland put up a
statue
um reciprocating statues recognizing
um what a significant contribution he's
made not just the university but to the
country I remember when they put it in
and I remember I think I was a almost
been a sophomore or a junior and I
remember thinking wow that's pretty cool
we don't put up statues and many
Founders anymore it was there was
already you know there's a huge leftist
tilt and I believe it at Princeton so I
was surprised then but very hardened
like of course this guy deserves a
statue and it should be right there
front and center outside of Firestone
Library uh in front of the chapel he's
facing the chapel which now doesn't
teach much about God but that's uh
another story it was just it was great
to see and there was no blowback
um there was a small ceremony I believe
and then I even wrote about it in the
prince Century which is the conservative
publication at Princeton just saying
like this is I think I suggested we
offer a course in the history of the
founders of Princeton or people at
Princeton there's so many interesting
people who should learn about them uh
and learn from them so the idea that his
statue would be removed is completely
antithetical to history antithetical to
what the university says it stands for
and would be bending to a really noisy
tiny percentage of radicals who now try
to get their way on any college campus
and the irony is Witherspoon was
anti-slavery it may have had two slaves
a lot of and almost every rich white
person did back then that's not to
rationalize it that's just to look at
reality then and he worked to free the
slaves and hoped and believed that the
founding generation would be one of the
last to own them so he was ahead of his
time on that and and not perfect nobody
is but my goodness it instead of tearing
him down getting rid of them we should
be celebrating him and teaching about
him there's a difference between
forgotten in a race forgotten is is you
know the last time someone's name is
spoken or generationally you know their
impact is is forgotten erased is
this is a significant person and we're
going to cancel or erase them so that
you never encounter the arguments that
they made because they were imperfect
people well we're all imperfect uh in in
one way or another so eraser is the most
dangerous aspect of it because the next
Generation it isn't even given an
opportunity to ReDiscover they're just
buried so it's happening across the
Spectrum it's on us to not let it happen
in big and small ways this seems like a
layup this is an easy one uh if if
Princeton has an ounce of courage but
they're going to sit in these little
listening sessions and they're gonna
listen to these little radical activist
undergraduates complain about their
super you know
um about their horrible privileged lives
at Princeton like a bunch of you know
babies and diapers uh who I mean it's
it's insane what we let them get away
with it takes just a little bit of
backbone a little bit of Education
um standing up to the Mob of of young
undergraduates who are really
um how would I put it
they're hyper self-assured and also
hyper uneducated so they're very
confident in their very shallow beliefs
based on talking points and virtue
signaling so I
I don't know where this will go but
places like Princeton will set the tone
places like Harvard and Yale and others
I mean they're all left-wing nonsense
Vacuums at this point but Princeton's
held out with Robbie George and some
conservative members the idea of free
thought giving into something like this
signals that you are also retreating
completely
[Music]